[Music]
want to know how i built this without
any code
stay tuned
[Music]
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning
and today i'm going to show you how to
train a sound classifier
with absolutely no code we are going to
use
teachable machines for this teachable
machines allows us to train a machine
learning model
right in the browser we can train it on
images
audio and poses with more to come we
gather the data
train the model and export it to use it
in our own projects
that's exactly what we will do today we
will create an audio project
record some samples of background noise
you might see a browser notification to
allow using the microphone
and i have already done that here so
once the audio is recorded
we extract these samples which are one
second
each for background noise it requires 20
samples
then take a few samples of clamping
sound
and we label them as cloud and here it
needs eight samples
of one second each let's record a few
samples for guitar sound
[Music]
now for our last label let's record a
few
bird sound samples i have this bird that
i got from
trip to mexico and it makes this
beautiful
bird chirp sound
once our labels are recorded all we need
to do is to train the model
since this is browser-based training
make sure to not close the window
while the model is training you might be
wondering what's happening under the
hood
well there is a lot happening but to
give you a quick sense these models use
a technique called
transfer learning there's a pre-trained
neural network
and when you create your own classes or
labels
the properties of these classes become
the last layer of that neural network
especially both the image and pose
models
learn off of the pre-trained mobile net
models and the sound model
is built on speech command recognizer
if you are curious to dive deeper
there's a blog linked below
just for you and it is
trained we can test it out right here
let me make the bird sound
and it rightly identifies it as our bird
label
if i clap it identifies it as
clap and if i play guitar
it identifies that too cool right
now that we are happy with our model we
can upload it to be hosted or downloaded
to use
directly in our app on uploading we get
a link to our model that we can copy and
use in our apps
let's test it right here in p5.js
replace our model url and if we run it
it shows the label text
now to make the output a little bit more
interesting let's add some fun emojis
for each label
and let's test it out again we play some
guitar
we play the bird chirp and we clap
now this is cool but i wanted to use
this as a web application
so i downloaded this html and javascript
from p5.js web editor
and decided to host a simple node.js web
app on cloudrun
pointed the index.js file to called
index.html that was
downloaded from p5.js and that's it
and here is the web app that can now
predict the sounds that we trained it on
if you're interested in the code i have
linked the github repository below
and that's how you do it we just trained
a sound classification model with
literally no code applied minor changes
to make our predictions fun
and then finally deployed it on cloud
run if you're feeling adventurous and
would like to get deeper into the sound
classification techniques
i've included a link to the tutorial
below thanks for watching and i look
forward to seeing you
next time with another tool in the ai
toolkit until then